hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Sarah is missing now this
is supposed to be an augmented reality
or kind of like altered reality game
where you're supposed to be finding
Sarah I'm assuming it was on heo Taz
supposedly it's supposedly just
different system failure your device ran
into a problem and needs to reset do you
want to restore your device to an
earlier time if you'd like to know more
no do I need to do oh my god I have to
oh okay please wait while we've story
our device do not switch off the Devoe's
at restoring iris okay restoring
messages okay
this phone appears to be you don't
appear to be Sarah what are you looking
at me have we met
oh okay I don't know should I go into my
goddamn messages oh geez I have no other
thing see welcome back Sarah this phone
appears to be damaged
ah you know what I have no idea if I
should talk to strangers but I'm gonna
do just that let's see oh I'm not Sarah
oh my nano jeez oh okay alright I have
to do what I have to do there alright
I'm not Sarah would you kindly return
this property back to Sarah young see
you know where she is
that's weird cuz it's the exact time
that it is right now based on your
response I assume she is not with you I
don't even know her it seems that the
last video she took implies that she is
in danger would you like to watch it and
help me verify nah no I wouldn't
no I don't want any part of this this
seems horrible and horrifying and why do
I have to help let's see what you got I
guess
I don't ever get feel at all cars I
don't want to see that hello oh I
thought I was gonna see someone getting
murdered oh that's so weird it's it's
really well done this is really well
made oh god it really replicates a phone
does the only file left at this moment
the rest of the content seems to be
deleted or intentionally damaged see how
much can you fix I assume I'm talking to
an AI it appears that only 14.3% of this
device is operational hey Sarah looks
like she needs help
do anything about it yes it would appear
so I am this Mobile's intelligent
recovery recognizance them it is in my
best interest and in your good
conscience to locate her immediately
I see why do you want it why do you want
me to help find Sarah she is my owner I
want to make sure she is safe it is my
prime directive okay whatever computers
start talking about prime directives
it's not exactly a good sign you sound
human yes I want jeez wait what we are
wasting precious time here will you help
me find Sarah but why did you just say I
want what did that mean in context to
this situation I have no idea what
you're going on about but okay how about
a big old year broody I don't know if I
could even say no here and oh no maybe
oh please
I believe you're her only hope the phone
is dying there's not much time I'm not
sure what Oh see there is no option I'm
not sure what I can do but okay I'll
help I don't even know
why I picked up this phone I need to
restore as much of the contents in this
phone as I'm able to please press the
back button then tap and hold anywhere
on the home screen mol added oh good
I've got a daily reminder that I need to
find Sara yeah there we go I believe I
can recover some of this phone's data
alrighty then do it to it
would you like me to restore them now
yeah no point waiting I guess am I gonna
get more flashes of nightmares oh boy I
can count on the nightmares on my way
this is gonna be fun remember you can
tap an older than any part of the phone
to ask me for help with anything oh okay
but if it's something out of my
capabilities I will let you know with a
beep okay I need help
oh thank you ah Thank You gallery okay
ah music okay okay so it's just that
he'll be here oh oh
normal LG's oh geez this doesn't look
good I feel really weird it's like I'm
actually going through someone's phone
here and this is weirdly private and I'm
invading the privacy right what do you
have to do this weekend swarm with my
work why I need a favor you always in
your favor what's new
Hado me mean I really want to go to this
gathering you mean party yeah I'm not
really up for it but it's sort of your
thing what do you mean it's volatile ich
möchte isn't that the witches feast how
is that my thing you're the pagan hey I
follow you to church alright what's the
big deal anyway
you're like into all these supernatural
stuff too yeah but I don't party with
ghosts I'm not gonna fall for one of
your coven initiations again faith oh
that was a joke come on Plus these
witches aren't real I bet I'm the only
real one around here just some guys
playing coven we all do it you know
Halloween hello I don't know faith maybe
not ask me again tomorrow or something
so that could be the start of something
bad that it was not gonna be a good
thing to go to that high mom just want
to check in Derek and I have decided to
end things things were now working out
so but I'm okay I'm hard to hear that
Sara blue I've always known that Derek
could never keep up with you best you
hunted things before I got too serious
what time is your flight back I have to
come out my driver pick you
from the airport right well mom actually
don't panic I've decided to stay Sara I
don't understand you've just come out of
a relationship and you're in a foreign
land why would you want to stay I need
some time for myself mom being home now
just I can't the only reason you can do
this is because you're living under my
roof and I'm paying for all your
expenses you've lived pretty comfortably
a pretty comfortable life and a spoilt
one at that I've given you nothing but
the best and all I've asked from you is
that you go for this one meeting and you
shoot it down without even thinking
about it
how ungrateful of you and your father he
was a good man
rest his soul but it's useless at living
he was a bum I won't stand for it if you
become like him Wow
okay mom going in for a meeting I'll be
home early today you'll have dinner at
home we will take further on this
wow what a overbearing mom I don't know
that that's is so overbearing and
controlling of her life so she's got an
overbearing mother who controls her life
tries to destined everything but
although that although she is going down
to Korea pass in parapsychology which I
don't even know what that is all right
what do we got here alright hey you
there what do you want just but bored
why should I care oh this is Derek oh so
man did you text me to tell me that
you're such an [ __ ]
Oh didn't mean to hurt you things were
different don't want us to end I guess I
don't know I'm trying to tell you this
was not how I plan to be things describe
yourself why do you always do this oh
god this feels so weird why am i reading
their private conversation stop blaming
this [ __ ] on girls on meat and these
girls naked or not they're not our
problems it's me what is he doing that
he's around naked girls who the [ __ ]
leaves their girlfriend to fly back to
another country to photograph nude women
on oh oh baby please baby please one
month a little less than a month month
baby baby please I'm not your baby
I'm not your baby okay all right bye
Wow this wee
so weird reading these conversations oh
boy
carpet flavored cop beans shop and air
bean all right nothing much here though
I shouldn't have gone into her pictures
I would have been very weird can you
help me with this virus I don't know
what to do as I calculated only a minor
portion of the phone contents are
available see where should I start
perhaps try going through a texture
stirry I just did what do I do if I find
something you should tap and hold on
anything interesting or suspicious I'll
lend my assistance and look into it god
dammit I just went through all the
messages now I gotta go back and
remember everything that I went through
okay iris I'm having some difficulty
there's something curious about faith
and ayahs text okay yeah that is true
okay so I remember that faith had a
weird thing where she wanted to go do
something I really want to go this
gathering what's going on there a
Walpurgisnacht what is that Jason she
said German what's the wall forget it's
not see is the one Dutch and German
names for the night of 30th of April so
called because it's the eve of the feast
of a saint Walburga an 80th century a
best front seal is believed to be the
night of a witches meeting people still
practice this freedom of religion or
freedom of belief is a principle to
support the freedom of individuality
okay I know that includes freedom to
change one's religion or belief
okey-dokey then I'm not gonna fall for
this again
nope okay so then I added one you're not
normally like this Sarah's actions it's
unusual how do you know what's unusual
through various calculations of Sarah's
regular activities and choices that she
makes under daily life I can simulate to
do center actions and inactions in the
situation does not matter perhaps for
here what Sarah usually like her
behavior shows that she's suffering from
abrupt and
apparent unaccountable change of moods
possibly due to a relationship issue but
I'm no doctor your freaky your freaky
iris I'm sorry okay okay okay hang on
I'll be right with you iris see if we
can look through her pictures I believe
there's an error with the gallery would
you kindly tapping all the Gallery icon
I don't like that feeling
please wait while I find what's wrong I
feel uncomfortable victors it seems
Sarah's kept it locked you will need a
passcode to proceed further the hint is
Sarah's birthday see can't you just tell
me I'm afraid I can't reveal personal
information you will need to find that
out for herself I know what a birthday
is I know I know it a lot yes it's in
her mail she has happy birthday on 14
she was born on Valentine's Day Derek is
an [ __ ] Wow
holy [ __ ] okay 14th of February Wow okay
one 402 take a closer look at the
strange photo in the gallery do that I
don't want to do that what's strange
which one strange okay let's see which
ones which ones weird oh boy nothing
nothing is this one weird how about that
one oh boy oh [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ]
is that what the [ __ ] is that what is
that see this photo correlates with the
video and a chat thread that Sarah
recently deleted
like me to retrieve the data yeah okay
please wait a moment
oh I'll wait here creep down oh my god
damn bind successfully restored the
Sierra's contact James the video should
be in the message thread alrighty then
okay James is it oh hey faith also has
more stuff here
faith has new messages Oh from the night
before she supposedly disappeared
according to ah yeah don't make me put a
smile on their Getty ass oh she's
talking about taking her out on the
thing oh boy yeah Derrick can stand you
home man
you didn't have to say that sorry too
soon talking about how long it's been
since the breakup oh boy convincing her
to go and if it sucks they'll leave
picking you up see you around 9 the
witch is cooking the bright side if she
finally poisoned you you don't have to
come Oh or mom's cooking oh I get it
oh jeez skinny oh boy presume you're
dead all right I'll come what are you
wearing I can tell you what I'm not
wearing [ __ ] bimbo [ __ ] fatty oh geez
alright where are you then waiting
aren't you picking up if you don't pick
up I'm leaving faith it's not funny I'm
in the middle of the jungle and I'm
alone where the [ __ ] are you okay okay
yo you busy got something if you're
interested thing called a Red Room I
know about that weird stuff online the
answers of stuff then BAM so you keep
going phone will start freaking out
pop-ups let me find the link
am I gonna die now okay you okay you
okay buddy
oh my controls are malfunctioning I
can't seem to bear can't even see what
it seems that the Red Room is connected
with the cult what do you mean by Redrum
Redrum a comp site urban legend
allegedly a hidden web site or service
in the Deep Web which can see and or
participate in act inactive interactive
torture and murder see
are you losing me found another mansion
that was recently deleted that might
held some clues I was able to restore
them for you okay could you kindly see
take a look at Razoo text thread okay
okay okay okay
hello there is this Sarah
received your contact from faith she
told me you're coming for a little party
hey or zoo I'm supposed to meet her here
what's going on I apologize but the
reception here is undesirably terrible
so this is judging by the timestamp this
is just after she was texting uh faith I
believe where are you I'm in the middle
of the jungle
I apologize reception bad no mobile
phones allowed I'm here to escort you
escort yes my dear it's hard to navigate
in the dark alone it's part of our
experience I'm not sure about this can I
talk to faith no you may not I apologize
but like I said phones are not allowed
she's safe they're probably drunk
already drunk faiths doesn't get drunk
how do I know you're really a friend
I've known her since high school never
met her never mentioned you keep a low
profile I'm not sure about this leave
surely you jest why I'm almost there
faith will be disappointed that you
didn't show she's made reservation for
you almost where to where you are of
course how do you know where I am faith
told me she was meeting you there I'd
prefer if you didn't come here please
I'm almost there please stop
worry you're safe I am going to ring you
please pick okay ah
oh hello ah what lovely symbols nice
those are great
those are real cool okay
orgies is this blood blood Damir filled
with lots of oral anal and case moles
are any then you cannot touch her though
something about a ritual here in some
sort of incantation recipes for the
ritual
okay iris iris is offline are you
can you see me I'm asked the cops I saw
okay James Oh James hi James
why don't you speaking I need to speak
with I need to talk to you James are you
there
hold on
okay was that a baby was that a baby
where am I where did I find this phone
it's urgent where are you you've been
missing for almost a day did you go to
that party please tell me you didn't
it's real bad news no boy see that
that's that'd be bad I'm not Sarah oh
boy
that's bad how bad is bad oh how about
is bad if only I can show you the
madness are you okay let's see I'm okay
you need to explain what's going on
you're some fire tell me what's wrong
with the party uh ssz right here check
this out I don't know if I sure I do
wanna check this out
those who are trying to prepare
themselves for entry into okay that was
great why did I need to see that that
doesn't sound like something I needed to
see see uh this is disturbing yeah oh
[ __ ] I see them huh oh my god
oh my [ __ ] god you won't believe this
cord okay see what what do you see ever
ever [ __ ] I think they sorry
we'll stop typing your dick James thanks
oh boy
well James probably dared changes
probably didn't know they didn't Jesus
that was [ __ ] close I'm hiding behind
this I don't know what this is oh I love
dead bodies
I'm conveniently placed
oh-oh-oh some weird going on with this
text bubbly
I probably shouldn't message and create
a sound on his device hello hello there
hello hello oh well that's no good
that's no good at all hello who is this
you're not James you are not Sara but
you pretend to be why see let's see what
does it matter so naive you know many
choices do not matter not as much as we
think anyway but this next choice you
make may what do you mean who am I
talking to
that doesn't seem good okay alright then
I'm assuming that's James see what
what's this interesting
what's this huh interesting
share this link with another anyone
everyone or say goodbye to a brief
acquaintance you have two minutes what
is it why are you doing this oh boy
share it
oh hang on wait James sent a photo well
please whoever you are do not do this I
feel like I must James might die iris oh
god what do I do
I should I don't know oh you wanna leak
you want a link e link uni group hey
everybody check out this cool thing it's
why I don't know what have you done I
have no idea no geez I didn't I did not
share the link well time to spread this
guy definitely deserves it all right
there you go see James sent a photo okay
hang on hang on oh wait oh that's no
good I shared it I never think that
people die they just go to the
departmental store what why Hey
the [ __ ] just happened you there I
shared it do you know what you shared
why don't you kill him after I shared it
I don't know what did he make me do it's
a death curse see there's no such thing
whether you believe me or not it is of
no consequence you shared it it is done
thank you see this doesn't make sense
many things in life make little to no
sense at all why did you do this hello
James
hi hello it is me again I apologize for
not introducing myself how rude of me
okay who the hell are you
your appearance was not expected but
here you are nonetheless my name is
arisu I am one of the how do you say
leaders for tonight's ceremony we have
met on a very fortunate night cherish
this moment my stranger friend see
you're asking me to celebrate a killing
please do not misunderstand my
intentions see then why as I said before
I do not kill and that man was anything
but poor he was a deceiver all these
choices what do these options mean what
are these options mean to you is this
your demonstration of free will see
can't you see I'm being forced hello you
don't even see how so what did he do you
will never be privy to that information
my young friend nor will you need it to
further your quest one quest what is
this where are my manners
I've told you my name and now what I do
I feel that my age is somewhat dulled
made these simple talk small talk as you
call it does not matter much what you do
but what's important for you to know my
young friend is that you like everything
else in this world you have a choice I'm
here to offer you that choice you didn't
offer James much of a choice trust me he
made his choices long ago time is of the
essence not reason fine what are my
options
ah now you understand you must ask the
right question the choice is simple yet
not see I'm listening a leap of faith
we're almost out of time so here it is
would you like to join us I believe you
have the potential it's rare for me to
offer to this someone who is uninitiated
yes or no simple yet not join who who
are you you're not telling me who you'll
find out soon enough if you have your
wits about you
quickly now yes or no see all I have to
do is say yes say these two young
ravishing women okay well I found Sarah
good for me alrighty then you choose
between them who lives to see the
sunrise tomorrow didn't you just say
you're not a killer but I do not it is
not my choice sacrifice is not the act
of pure destruction it is merely a
transformation life is perpetual I leave
it up to you God Himself makes these
decisions all the time
why not ease some of the work for him or
see or her or it however you want to see
it Sarah or faith their names mean
nothing to you but to us they are what
binds them to this flesh and mud say one
of their names and know that it will be
their last breath there is no sweeter
invite than a last breath to welcome you
one passes and another comes what say
you
why me that's an excellent question I
just found a phone why why not it is fun
since you are here anyway why not choose
life in everything in life is a choice
whether you join us or not it makes no
difference
yes or no Sara or faith you have ten
seconds wait they will they will be no
more uh I don't know I'm here to save
Sara I think those all bornus you
specified that oh gee oh I don't look at
that oh that's no good I don't see that
the deed is done welcome my child you're
being answer me this why did you choose
faith how do I get to this point what
it's all meaningless
oh geez it may seem meaningless for now
but life has as much meaning as we put
into it come now to these coordinates I
did not want this outcome I was just
trying to get some more information nah
I have done real bad I can't even back
out now I can't do anything
Oh No I've oh boy can you help me about
this huh hello Oh red iris it's a tough
choice but had to be done
I don't know Sara means too much to me
it hurts to see faith go Sara new faith
for the longest time I don't want to do
this I don't want anyone to die I hope
it doesn't wide well you might be dead
life hurts a lot more than death key at
least Sara is okay we need to find her
quick this is so weird
this is Seoul
okay wait hang on you've made it this
far too bad you won't make it much
further but know that you have now
become part of something much longer all
will be revealed in due time another
sentence any last words as you humans
are so fond of leaving words behind it's
not that I don't love our little chats
it's just so weird
how many secrets are strewn about that
game how many things could you click and
hold on to be there and investigate
further I'm almost positive I did not
get a good ending if there's multiple
endings to this game I did not get a
good one that's for damn sure so I
actually might restore this game because
there is so much there
I didn't even pour through the rest of
the pictures I didn't even go through
the videos I went through none of that
but that was so interesting I can't stop
thinking about that
my god that burrowed into my brain it
felt so real even though I was literally
just looking at a phone screen like for
some reason that made it more real that
was so weird
oh man okay so this game is trying to
get on scene greenlight this game should
definitely be on Steam and it's
available on heo at a name your own
price interval I would recommend bang a
few bucks to the developer to just fuel
this kind of thing because that was just
harrowing like harrowing but incredibly
interesting so let me know what you
think down in the comments below and I
will revisit this in the future if
there's something to see so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the mysteries of this through the link
in the description below and as always I
will see you in the next video